منذ حصولي حكومه نتنياهو الجديده على ثقه
الكنيست قبل نحوي ثلاثه اسابيع لا يمر يوم
من دون ارتفاع في المسار التصعيدي في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله في الخليل
قتلت قوات الاحتلال الفلسطينيه اخر ليصبح
الشهيد الخامس عشر منذ بدايه العام في حين
تواصلت في مدن الضفه الغربيه حملات الدهم
والاعتقالات تركز احداثها في مخيم الفوار
جنوب الخليل حيث اعتقل الجيش الاسرائيلي
10 فلسطينيين ليرتفع بذلك عدد المعتقلين
منذ بدايه العام الجاري الى اكثر من 235
فلسطينيه
بالنسبه الى الحكومه الاسرائيليه فكل ذلك
ياتي في اطار الحفاظ على الامن وتحت ظل
هذه الحجه يمكن التعامل مع اي رد فعل تجاه
تحركاتها واجراءاتها فحتى لو وقعت 39 دوله
بيانا يطالب اسرائيل بالتراجع الفوري عن
الاجراءات العقابيه التي اتخذتها ضد
الفلسطينيين
بعيدان موافقه الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده على قرار يطلب من محكمه العدل
الدوليه ابداء رايها في مساله شرعيه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للضفه الغربيه والقدس
الشرقيه فان هذا لا معنى له وفق وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي اليكوهن ولن تمنع
حكومته من اتخاذ القرارات الصحيحه لحمايه
مواطنها على قاعده امن اسرائيل اولا في
مسار تصعيدي اخر استدعته وزاره الخارجيه
الاردنيه السفيره الاسرائيليه في عمان
وابلغته رساله احتجاج شديده اللهجه بعد
نعيش شرطه الاحتلال دخول السفير الاردني
في تل ابيب غسان المجالي الى المسجد
الاقصى مشترطه حصوله على اذن مسبق للقيام
بزياره وذكر بيان الخارجيه الاردنيه ان
رساله الاحتجاج اكدت ادانت عمان لكل
الاجراءات الهادفه للتدخل غير المقبول في
شؤون المسجد الاقصى